it is almost that time to start saying
new year new me and if you're
considering aesthetic procedures parasol
Aesthetics the sponsors of this segment
have non-surgical options for you so
let's welcome Erica Lauren and to the
Show and her lovely model Agnes we're
all talking about we're giving fall
Aesthetics here loving all the colors
yes no I I imagine the holidays are a
very busy time for you guys in this
industry right we have a lot of people
coming in right now like they want to
get beautified before New Year's and
Christmas and it's like what can I do
for my skin type for my aging where I'm
at so there are three main pillars for
anti-aging so one of them would be
botulinum toxin for wrinkles two would
be dermal fillers to help fill in where
you have deep creases and if lots of fat
and three would be doing like
non-surgical facelifts and things to
tighten skin so I'm just going to kind
of show you a nerve model Agnes so the
main thing or the first thing would be
the bachelinum toxins which you'll find
in different brands so Botox and dysport
CM and juvo it works in the upper
forehead glabella area and around the
crow's feet here so what it does that
you can think after injecting it's like
pulling the string out of a blind so
that everything falls down right yeah
that's a good way nice and smooth
thinking that's beautiful now I
competition
very special one yeah let's talk about
that yes so we're doing a holiday
competition Agnes is our first winner
we're looking for women who have been
through maybe a tough time a tough few
years and they really could use a
pick-me-up so we're hoping that people
will nominate themselves or friends or
co-workers who you know could use a
makeover from the inside and out so
we'll do beautiful yeah like Aesthetics
and we'll do some hair and makeup with
Abby May and we'll do a wardrobe with me
and my laundry we've got to awk I Love
It Agnes how special is that for you
it's so excellent so so grateful and so
thankful of course of course and of
course with that makeover you get some
products you get the work so let's talk
about what you have over here on the
table Yeah so that second pillar we were
talking about would be to as women age
and Men We both lose our bony prominence
here and around the face we also lose
fat pads that go along here underneath
the eyes and they start to shift and
move apart like Islands when that
happens everything slides forward and
then you get these big deep creases here
the lower face gets heavy so I want to
refill with a dermal filler which would
be a hyaluronic acid and you want to
remember people come in they're worried
about getting too much filler one
syringe of filler has the size of a
blueberry in it so per decade of Life
you'll need like at one syringe per
decade of life good to know so that's
see you go in to see her and you get a
full list of tips for you know making
over during the holidays and Beyond so I
hear you have some holiday deals can you
just invite everybody down yep so we're
going to have some Black Friday specials
you're going to buy one syringe of
dermal filler you'll get the second half
off we're going to have 50 off our CO2
laser and PDO thread lifts and that's
the third pillar so that's going to be
tightening after everything else is done
that's like the cherry on the Sunday oh
yes three steps to looking your best for
the holidays okay so thank you to
Parasol Aesthetics and ladies thank you
Dermatology and wellness for sponsoring
this segment call
702-560-6776 or just visit the
parasolcompanies.com for more